the Kovan 19 coronavirus is still
spreading but while one early study
found that 80% of cases are considered
mild the definition of mild can include
a range of symptoms and still be painful
even though cases might not require
hospitalization I have mild symptoms I'm
coughing but am i coughing once every
minute or is it every 10 minutes or five
minutes and if that starts to get more
and more frequent the exam copying every
two minutes now every one minute and now
I can't even speak to you because I'm
running out of breath those are the
things that would trigger me pick up the
phone saying hey you know what things
are actually worse that's doctor Rishi
Desai the chief medical officer at
osmosis
he says fatigue is the most common
symptom of the corona virus but there
are some other ones to watch out for so
typically it slows you down it causes
fatigue or malaise you might be less
inclined to get up and do work and maybe
a sore throat so maybe some vocal
symptoms like that you can have a runny
nose you can have some congestion and
you knows that inflammation in your nose
makes it hard to smell it can also
affect your taste so all the sudden
things that you usually would really
enjoy you're not really enjoying those
foods anymore a lot of what I'm
describing to be perfectly honest is a
lot of the same sort of general symptoms
or mild symptoms yet with the common
colds likewise the way to mitigate your
mild coronavirus symptoms is largely the
same way you'd relieve your typical cold
for example you would drink a lot of
fluids you'd make sure those fluids have
a little bit of salt and a little bit of
sugar in them because that way you get
the fluid absorbed into your body so a
great example that would be broth or
soup you'd make sure in general you're
hydrated and that you're peeing multiple
times a day you'd want to trigger your
fever and see if the fever is getting
better or worse and if it's getting
worse maybe you take a medication like
Tylenol the one thing that's different
that you would do with kovat is that
you'd monitor your symptoms really
closely because if they're getting worse
then you'd want to call and make sure
you get seen the CDC says that if you're
experiencing symptoms you think may be a
result of Cova night
seek medical attention by calling your
doctor first if you have an underlying
condition like diabetes asthma
cardiovascular disease or cancer and you
think you might have contracted the
coronavirus desai says you should be
seeking medical attention immediately
for those with mild symptoms it's
extremely important to monitor them to
prevent the spread of coronavirus do
your best to limit contact with people
stay vigilant by washing your hands
cleaning the surfaces you use daily and
monitoring your health